well we can't talk about award shows
without talking about fashion of course
and this weekend you can celebrate in
style at the forum shops joey such a
doll ski from all saints and john
barbados is here to get us fashion ready
thanks for being here thanks for having
me you came in all the way from new york
i did and i feel like new york is a very
fashionable place so i trust you but
let's talk about what's going on here
this weekend it's a fun weekend it's an
exciting weekend here in vegas we're
going to be having a great party at our
store forum shops tomorrow night so feel
free to come out but uh for today
excited to show you some great looks yes
we have some fun models off to the side
over here so i say we bring them in
let's talk about it let's see what
they're wearing come on in we got our
first model here looking good in full
john varvatos um so a nice casual day
look a lot of great texture a lot of
great earth tones and color perfect for
the desert i love it yes desert chic yes
indeed absolutely all right i see a hat
yeah i'd love hats it wouldn't be the
grammys without a hat that's right what
do we have here we have more of an
evening look here great transitional
great boots a lot of good texture and of
course the hat looking good i feel like
the shades are a must inside or inside
or outside absolutely all right next up
we have a very special guest i have to
mention she's our intern say hello to
lina looking cute it looks so great i
love this dress a lot of texture and a
lot of versatility can kind of take a
day to night leather jacket a little bit
of a rocker touch to it of course music
inspired grammy's weekend can't go wrong
she looks so cute i feel like you just
found your new career you're working
that camera in those angles
all right our next model too is also
part of our las vegas now family maria
she's looking good yes and this is
another great look that you can really
transition day to night take it from a
great brunch to a grammy's after party
super comfortable
yes
absolutely a good kind of shawl it's
almost like you can have two looks in
one that's exactly it you can really
kind of dress it up dress it down add
some jewelry if you wanted to add some
jewelry to it great from day to night oh
my gosh she is looking good
all right and if you notice we were
wearing the same shoes so i have to
mention that you did dress me too we're
having so much fun in the dressing room
thank you so is this is this in right
now the cold shoulder it is it is
definitely and it looks great on you and
it's in our store forum shops right now
if you want to go pick it up it's funny
you had a hanger with a few options and
i was like that one i like this one all
right let's bring our models back in
because they're all looking so great and
so this weekend what's going on at the
party can people come in and shop and
hang out
shop we're going to have food we're
going to have a dj it'll be a great
opportunity to uh celebrate grammy's
weekend here in vegas and we have to
talk about your look for a second here
john varvatos i am loving this and the
shoes are matching the jacket i'm all
about like coordination but is that like
matchy exactly okay i think you know
something like this it's the texture
leather suede denim really um texture
really can really make it work yeah well
you're looking good of course and really
quickly you know we're about to see the
red carpet all the celebrities coming
through i'm putting you on the spot but
is there anyone that is like your
fashion icon or someone that you look
forward to seeing what they're going to
do on the carpet you know i think the
fun thing about grammys is that it's
very unpredictable you never know what
you're going to get
so i think that's what's most exciting
is to kind of see what comes down the
red carpet there's been a lot of great
moments in history so it'll be fun to
see what happens yeah and it's kind of
fun the oscars are always glamorous but
this like you can have a little more fun
yeah absolutely well i trust you with my
life to style we have all the
information on the screen that party is
happening tomorrow saturday april 2nd go
hang out and i mean come on you can
leave looking like all of our beautiful
models here all of this is in stores
right now so you can have it exactly
looking good
all right from fashion to the swag
topgolf